hello everyone and welcome to today's a
live broadcast surveillance and ai
powered prediction of amr to inform
antibiotic therapy i am sydney mcneill
of lab roots and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by opgen a precision medicine
company harnessing the power of
molecular diagnostics and bioinformatics
to help combat life-threatening
infectious diseases and fight
anti-microbial resistance to improve
patient care
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their site at optgen.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation report your problem by
clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i would like to now introduce our
presenter dr arna materna managing
director and ceo of aries genetics in
option group company
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
on the right side of your screen dr
materna you may now begin your
presentation
hello and thank you for tuning in to the
seminar my name is anne matana and i'm
the ceo of aries genetics and over the
course of the next 30 or 40 minutes i
will speak about how machine learning
when combined with sequencing based
solutions can help us overcome
limitations in how we currently address
the global challenge of antibiotic
resistant or amr pathogens
but first a few words about aries
genetics we are based in vienna austria
and we're part of the option group of
companies together with curators and
option we address amr with cutting edge
molecular diagnostics and genomic
testing
while courage is an object developed pcr
based ibd testing
aerys genetics was founded to harness
the potential of next generation
sequencing and ai-based solutions
i'd like to begin the seminar with a few
facts on antimicrobial resistance
while the attention of many of us quite
rightfully is on the impact of the
current cobit 19 pandemic
another severe pandemic is on the rise
the antibiotics which we all have come
to rely upon as an effective treatment
of otherwise often dangerous and maybe
even deadly infections
they are slowly but steadily becoming
ineffective we see a global increase in
pathogens that prove resistant against
standard and even against last resort
antimicrobial therapy
with already tens of millions affected
by antimicrobial resistance or amr
and dozens of billions in euros per year
in direct healthcare costs the probably
most severe consequence we face are the
over 700 000 fatalities each year that
amounts to over 2 000 deaths each day
and by some estimates these numbers are
expected to rise within about a
generation to 10 million
per year meaning
amr would eclipse
as a leading cause would eclipse cancer
as a leading cause of death
the problem of amr is made worse by the
challenge of choosing the right
treatment
now predicting how an infected patient
will respond to antibiotic therapy is a
heart problem which is influenced by
factors such as the genomics of the
pathogen causing the infection
and as a consequence only a minor only a
minority of patients are receiving
appropriate treatment a fact that has
become once more apparent in the over
treatment of cobit patients during this
pandemic with antibiotics in order to
quell potential bacterial co-infections
internal studies have shown that in fact
only 15
of patients receive appropriate
antibiotics while 63 of all patients are
over treated with ineffective
antibiotics
and to explain the significance of
overtreatment it is worthwhile
taking a look at the emergence and
evolution of amr
as you probably know and as every
microbiologist will tell you
antibiotic compounds and resistance
mechanisms evolve naturally as
part of the competition between microbes
which are competing for resources in the
same ecological niche
the problem arises when natural amr
mechanisms are met with inappropriate
use of ineffective antibiotics
which causes any existing and newly
evolved amr mechanisms to sweep through
the entire bacterial population and
whenever such a situation is then met
with imperfect or poor hygiene and
infection prevention and control
then outbreaks of amr or mdr pathogens
are the consequence
fueling this vicious cycle of antibody
consumption
increasing the demand for new
antibiotics and so on
the question therefore is what can be
done to break this vicious cycle leading
to amr
on one hand we rely on the
pharmaceutical industry to keep
developing novel forms of antibiotic
therapy the challenge for pharma thereby
is that the new drug development be or
that any new drug development becomes a
race against the evolution of resistance
mechanisms
while an encouraging number of 70 drugs
is currently in different stages of
clinical and pre-clinical development
the who notes in its report from this
year on antibiotic drug candidates that
currently over 80 percent of newly
approved drugs
can be rendered ineffective by existing
resistance mechanisms
this means that drug development alone
is not enough to effectively control amr
global health organizations are
therefore calling for antimicrobial
stewardship to help us regain the
advantage over amr
antimicrobial stewardship refers to
technologies and interventions that
promote the optimal use and that avoid
the overuse of
antibiotics which in turn
not only improves patient outcomes but
also reduces the emergence of antibiotic
resistance
antibiotic stewardship however depends
on technology for diagnostics and
surveillance
while rapid diagnostic tests capable of
determining whether a pathogen will
respond to therapy with resistance or
not
have the potential to enable a more
targeted antibiotic therapy
the majority of antibiotic prescriptions
today
are empirically informed thanks to
surveillance data
so let's take a look at the technologies
that are in the clinic today
the standard of care in infectious
disease diagnosis are bacterial cultures
which are routinely used for the
identification of infective agents and
the determination of suitable antibiotic
treatment options
whenever a culture is positive meaning
if pathogen growth is present
then until so-called antibiotic
susceptibility testing or referred to as
ast
is performed in order to determine
which antibiotics are effective and
which will likely be met with resistance
so ast determines the risk or seeks to
determine the resistance phenotype or
amr phenotype
while these culture based methods are
being considered the gold standard they
are often very labor intensive
and may miss difficult to culture
pathogens
the turnaround times range from one to
three days or more
which is long considering that patients
with acute infections require urgent
care within hours
this lack of sensitivity and speed is
addressed by modern molecular tests
relying on pcr
leading pcr panels such as the tests
available on the curator's universe
system achieve very high sensitivities
and can turn around results in a matter
of hours or even pushing the limit below
one hour these days
however these systems can only screen
for up to a few hundred biomarkers at
best
this means each essay which has to be
individually developed validated and
potentially approved by the regulators
can cover only a limited number of
pathogens and for each pathogens again
only a very limited number of genetic
markers for amr
given that the number of known genetic
markers for amr is today measured in the
thousands the question has to be
is there a system that could
simultaneously and comprehensively
screen for any pathogen and all known
genetic markers for antibiotic
resistance
and what if the system would not only
report the detected amr markers but also
emulate the advantages of culture
by predicting whether detective
pathogens are susceptible or resistant
to antibiotic therapy
here is where next generation sequencing
or abbreviated ngs enters the picture
ngs is increasingly adopted by clinical
labs and its utility for microbial
typing and epidemiology is already
undisputed
ngs is therefore also in the center of
attention for
of aries genetics
it is the first technology that thanks
to an enormous sampling depth it's not
only very sensitive but also captures
the entire genome allowing for an
exhaustive characterization of genetic
emo markers amr markers in a single test
moreover such comprehensive genomic
information provides a chance to use
artificial intelligence and predictive
modelling to emulate culture based
antimicrobial susceptibility testing and
to predict which antibiotics represent
suitable treatment options
with the sequencing costs as well as
turnaround times rapidly decreasing
trying to overcome the shortcomings in
the current standard of care through
sequencing based predictive
antimicrobial susceptibility testing has
firmly emerged as
a focus for our development teams
as we set out to develop
rapid and accurate sequencing-based
methods for the comprehensive detection
of pathogens and amr and the prediction
of
bacterial response to antibiotic therapy
we quickly realized that a key component
in the entire workflow were amr marker
databases
when we evaluated several public emo
market databases for their suitability
for predictive asd or resistance
prediction
we recognized
several shortcomings that i'd like to
present to you here
one issue was that genetic amr markers
in public databases were annotated at
the level of antibody classes which was
two cores for machine learning
considering that different antibiotic
compounds in the same class
can be affected differently by any given
amr marker or mechanism for example due
to differences in enzymatic
affinities
therefore raising the resolution of
marker annotation in the databases from
antibiotic class to the level to the
compound level substantially improved
predictive modeling
another issue we have identified was
that simple rule-based models for
individual markers tended to over
generalize
because multiple genetic factors can for
example synergistically or
antagonistically contribute to the mr
phenotype we needed to adjust for
biology and allow for polyvariate
predictive models
based on these and other findings we
decided to develop airsdb a
comprehensive mr knowledgebase designed
from ground up to enable predictive asd
airsdb today is a globally leading
database of curated mr amar markers and
information about resistance derived
from genotypic and phenotypic data
what sets arsdb apart from other
databases is not only comprehensiveness
but also that it harbors a continuously
growing collection of clinical pathogen
genomes and associated validated asd
measurements that determine how a given
pathogen in this database has responded
phenotypically
in the lab when exposed to a wide range
of antibiotics
this additional data layer offers
two unique benefits
the genotype phenotype phenotype data
association can be used for machine
learning
specifically in order to discover novel
biomarkers for amr
and on the other hand to train
predictive models that can predict how
pathogens respond to therapy based on
genomic data
a process we refer to as predictive ast
or past because it generates
just like conventional asd a antibiogram
currently the models to predict
antibiotic susceptibility are trained as
stacked ensemble models which associate
phenotypic ast results and a variety of
genetic markers including for instance
k-mers gene models
mutation score annotations and so on
within the rsdb
this model-based approach can be
complemented by a rule-based approach
taking into account the interplay
between multiple resistance mechanisms
and antibody compounds
as the figure in the middle illustrates
we're not only relying on the presence
absence of certain well-known resistance
genes but we also consider changes in
non-coding regions of the genome as well
as novel markers for example in
regulatory regulatory regions and other
parts of the genome that our predictive
algorithms have discovered
we demonstrated in several studies the
high categorical agreement between the
standard of care results with the
resistance phenotypes we predicted based
on genomic data
these studies for instance also include
the first and only multi-center
evaluation which successfully
demonstrated the feasibility and the
performance of predictive ast for 13
pathogens causing lower
respiratory infections
as you can see in this graphic on the
right side
we obtained a cohort of
patients for which culture uh positive
isolates were subjected to standard of
care testing more specifically to um asd
using both micro micro dilution testing
and maldi tof for pathogen
identification
in parallel we extracted dna from
such isolates and subjected them to
genome sequencing and downstream
bioinformatics analysis using aerys
cloud the results were compared for
concordance
this result this this slide is quite
busy but allowing me to walk you through
through some of the results shown here
along the horizontal axis you can see
the 13 pathogens that were identified by
the standard of care along the vertical
axis you can see the different
antibiotic compounds grouped into
compound classes and the intersections
in this matrix correspond to the percent
categorical agreement of our resistance
prediction with the measured phenotype
in the laboratory
if you now exclude those pathogens which
are intrinsically resistant against
certain compounds here shown in blue
and those in gray for which the standard
of care did not yield any result then
the white intersections um
are the ones
to focus on when comparing errors pasd
with culture-based antimicrobial
susceptibility testing
for the majority of these intersections
now highlighted in green we were able to
demonstrate high concordance a reaching
for most of the pathogen drug
combinations values significantly above
the regulatory threshold for asd devices
which is at 90
often achieving values up to 100
studies like this are not only important
for clinical validation purposes we also
embrace them as they give our data
science teams clear indicators on which
pathogen drug combinations to focus our
efforts on for predictive model
development as well as for database
curation
here the result of such an effort to
improve model performance for a given
drug pathogen combination through
focused biocuration and model training
together with partners such as reference
labs we generate and aggregate isolate
genomes and the corresponding phenotypic
data on amr
the data here show that by increasing
the number of specific isolates as you
can see here along the x-axis
um
not only the categorical agreement but
also the so-called very major error rate
which is the false susceptible rate
shown here on the y-axis can be
systematically improved and reduced here
to levels that are in line with ibd
device regulation
the benefit for our partners thereby
resides in being able to accurately
predict treatment response directly from
genomic surveillance data
and of course um in having access to an
up-to-date amr market database for their
civilians efforts
over the next couple of slides i would
like to talk about the development of
solutions based on rsdb and predictive
modeling and
the validation of such solutions
here
a number of products and services that
are essentially enabled by rsdp
starting with testing as a service which
is offered through our vienna based next
generation sequencing services lab we
are offering ares iss iss stands for
isolate sequencing for example for
infection prevention and control
surveillance and clinical r d
in contrast to iris iss rsupa
is a universal pathogenum essay
which
seeks to identify pathogens and amr in
native specimen and without the need for
prior culture both assays accept either
dna
errors iss also accepts isolated
material and irs upa accepts native
patient or environmental specimen
it's important to point out that areas
upa at the moment is in early access
testing with customers in different
countries
in addition to testing as a service
ares also offers interpretation as a
service through a bioinformatics product
called aries cloud
the
aries cloud is a bioinformatics cloud
portal for pathogen identification
typing as well as the amr
characterization it is powered by our
ai-based predictive algorithms and the
proprietary rsdb
here another visualization of aries db
and enabled solutions i'd like to
start by providing further details on
aeris ism
before i continue i'd like to apologize
in case there is acoustic feedback i'm
getting some feedback every time i
switch the slides and i hope it does not
affect this uh this seminar
back to irs is the isolated sequencing
service as i mentioned the service is
offered through our vienna based
service laboratory and the service is
designed to meet the requirements of
clinical microbiologists
we accept either culture or dna as
starting material can deliver short long
reads
and rapid turnaround times are available
upon request
clients can conveniently access raw data
bioinformatic analysis results and the
final reports for the rs cloud portal
the reports identify primary and
secondary pathogens as well as
mlsd and core genome mlsd genotyping
results
in addition to antibiogram prediction we
offer a comprehensive characterization
of detected markers for amr plasmids as
well as virulence factors
we also deliver information on strain
relatedness and conduct detailed
outbreak analysis and we can offer
custom bioinformatics support
to ensure the accurate performance of
our platform we routinely validate our
workflows and publish the results along
with the validation protocols here is
the example of a study validating rs iss
and the analysis in the following clia
guidelines
clia is a us standard for laboratory
developed testing
the performance was assessed recording a
number of parameters including accuracy
repeatability and reproducibility as
well as sensitivity and specificity
the study showed that ares iss
proves 100 percent accurate and
reproducible
for pathogen identification and
genotyping
also among detection was highly accurate
with sensitivities and specificities
exceeding 95 and 99 respectively
with nanopore sequencing becoming
increasingly available we have just
conduct conducted a multi-center
validation study of
ares isolate sequencing using the ont
platform ont hereby stands for the
platform by oxford nanopore technologies
nanopore sequencing is an interesting
platform for clinical microbiology for a
number of reasons for one the turnaround
time
um
sorry for one the turnaround time is low
theoretically enabling same-day
reporting and workflows as short as four
to six hours
the technology also generates long reads
which offer interesting advantages for
the assembly of bacterial genomes or for
the recovery of plasmids
finally the small footprint and the low
capital equipment cost as well as the
per base cost make this an interesting
platform for clinical or surveillance
applications
nanopore sequencing works by
translocating a single dna strand across
a biological pore and a membrane or
through a biological pore and across the
membrane sorry
a steady flow of ions
through that pore creates thereby a
current which can be measured and
which fluctuates in a dna sequence
specific pattern as dna is translocated
through this pore
the downside is that both the nanopore
itself as well as the dna translocating
effect rely on life biological proteins
which introduce biological variability
into the system leading to less accurate
base calling compared for instance to
illuminate short rates
in order to determine if and how less
accurate long rates affect the
bioinformatics we use for iris isolate
sequencing
we conducted a multi-center validation
the well-characterized
set of reference materials was subjected
to dna extraction by
using kits by different vendors and the
resulting dna extracts were aliquoted
and sent to omt enabled partner labs so
laboratories with access to oxford
nanocore technology platforms for
library preparation and sequencing using
the 10.4 flow cells
and the rapid library sorry rapid
library preparation chemistry by omt
indeed the base calling quality was
reduced we obtained quality or q scores
on the fret scale of 11 to 12 for ont
compared to much higher q scores in the
range of 30 we typically see with
illumina data
however the assembly process that
follows resolves some of these problems
after the noble genome assembly we
assessed the average nucleotide identity
of the assembled genomes with the known
public reference and determined that the
error rate was only three to four fold
higher compared to illumina-based
assemblies
despite this remaining unresolved
difference in sequencing quality the
errors bioinformatics pipeline for rs
isolate sequencing performed very well
the accuracy and reproducibility for
pathogen identification um it was
robustly hundred percent
we also obtained high accuracies for
ammo marker profiling and plasmid
detection which were only slightly below
the performance
of illumina data
most satisfying was the fact that the
antibiogram prediction using predictive
asd performed very well with an accuracy
of up to 97
and in line with illumina data
we believe that this performance is owed
to the stacked ensembling
stacked ensemble modeling approach i
described earlier
this approach associates not not just
one but a number of different genomic
features with phenotype with phenotypic
resistance data and therefore
uh it appears to be rather robust to ngs
error
the only area where nanopore technology
can further improve is bacterial typing
which at the moment appears to be more
sensitive to sequencing error
but we have enrolled with oxford
nanopore technologies in their q20
program promising drastic quality
increases and are prepared and are
preparing the next evaluation as we
speak
i'd like to shift gears and talk a bit
about the software platform eris cloud
which we use to evaluate data from iris
isolate sequencing
aerys cloud is a user-friendly
cloud-based portal which fully automates
the analysis of long and short-read data
from for instance clinical isolates
rs cloud returns comprehensive reports
information on sequencing quality and
contamination
pathogen identity and gene and genotype
also included are predicted antibiograms
which clearly identify implicated
antibiotics
from here users can drill into rich
information on individually detected mr
markers their prevalence and prognostic
performance
also included is information on plasmids
and virulence factors
all reports can be explored
online within the rs cloud user
interface or exported with the click of
a button
for convenience the iris cloud also
includes a set of comparative analysis
tools for the investigation of local
bacterial outbreaks
i would like to conclude the overview
over ares products and services with the
rsupa
this universal pastor genome assay is
designed to detect pathogens and amr
markers directly in native and
potentially poly microbial patients
specimen or environmental samples
the culture-free detection of emr
markers in native materials is quite
challenging
even for ultra deep shotgun metagenomic
sequencing as i will show you in a
minute
the issue is that accurately and
reproducibly recovering individual mr
markers such as for instance a mutation
in a gyrace gene
is is very problematic
as the majority of dna in such samples
comes from human or environmental
background
to overcome what essentially is a
sampling problem we have therefore
developed an essay relying on target
capture sequencing
thanks to rsdb we are able to design
baits that comprehensively cover known
mr markers including resistance genes as
well as resistance in using mutations
the
8090 baits
capture over 9 000 amr genes and alleles
and
we ensure that unlike for metagenomic
sequencing near complete marker coverage
of close to 100
and twofold tiling of each amro a marma
amr locus sorry is accomplished
this slide shows the performance of
metagenomics for amar market detection
in four environmental samples as you can
see in the table on the left hand side
the number of mr markers that can be
recovered is rather small and as the
chart on the right hand side shows the
ammo marker coverage is in fact
sequencing depth dependent which is
further impacting the cost and the
sensitivity of the shotgun metagenomic
sequencing
now let's take a look at how rsupa
as you see the number of mr markers
which can be reproducibly recovered
drastically increases compared to
metagenomics
and also the marker coverage is
consistently consistently near 100 and
independent of next generation
sequencing depth
so in summary the rsupa represents a
sensitive and cost-effective alternative
to metagenomics it also offers thanks to
rsdb-informed design an amr marker panel
which in terms of its comprehensiveness
eclipses with more than 9000 covered
markers any other amr panel we are aware
of
15 gears once again i will now present a
number of clinical cases of newly
emerging antimicrobial resistance and
the attempt by researchers and
clinicians at the john hopkins
university and hospital to define the
associated mr markers and mechanisms
the clinical cases focus on resistance
to cephederoco which makes them
particularly concerning because
cepherocol is a relatively new compound
reserved for last resort therapy
a few words on the background
um the magnitude of carbopedia
resistance in gram-negative bacteria has
reached an alarming level
in recent years several new antibiotics
have become available for clinical use
however these new agents have a limited
spectrum of activity when compared with
cevideracore
cefiderocl has been developed following
an interesting approach
and
it is to my knowledge still the first
and only compound of this type that has
passed regulatory approval
safiderocol is a synthetic conjugate
composed of different moieties that
promote for instance entry into the
bacterial cell
and antibacterial
antibacterial activity there's also
moieties that improve its stability to
beta-lactamases
for example a cephalosporin moiety
inhibits cell wall synthesis and acts in
an antimicrobial fashion
and a carticular type citroform moiety
gains entry into the bacterial cells by
using
active iron iron transporters
making the drug essentially independent
of usual points of entry such as porin
channels or efflux pumps
cefiderocol is an intriguing compound
with great promise for clinical efficacy
against a broad range of aerobic
gram-negative pathogens
and as a consequence it is important to
be able to diagnose and understand
resistance
mechanisms and avoid inappropriate use
of this antibiotic
in a first study published in microbial
drug resistance this year the authors
sought to identify mechanisms leading to
baseline resistance against cifideron
surveillance data empirically show that
the compound is 100 active in
introductory alleys which have not
previously been exposed to cefederical
however carbapenem resistant
androbacteriales or cres
exhibit an increased minimal inhibitory
concentration at which cellular coral is
effective
even if they have not been pre uh
predisposed to um cefideroco
in an attempt to identify baseline
mechanisms the authors collected and
sequenced 56 cre isolates from eight
different species predominantly
klebsiella pneumoniae e coli and
enterobacter chloek complex
the sequencing results were analyzed and
queried against the rsdb using the iris
cloud pipeline
the results indicated that cefederical
resistance in cre likely has no single
mechanism
leading to baseline resistance
instead saffidorcal resistance seems to
result from a combination of
heterogeneous mechanisms including
different beta lactamases and mc
beta-lactamases
approaching the problem from a different
angle the team expanded their view to
include pseudomonas aeruginosa with a
difficult to treat resistance phenotype
or dtr phenotype
um
these are
all dtr pseudomonas aerognosia isolates
are resistant to essentially all
beta-lactams fluoroquinolones and
therefore pose a significant clinical
challenge
dtr pseudomonas aeruginosa strains even
respond with elevated resistance to new
drug combinations like
keftalosan tesobactum
and others after being exposed to these
compounds
which leaves cepheid oracle in these
cases as a precious last alternative
after reports that dtr pseudomonas
aeruginosa strains also develops a
federal resistance after treatment with
a capital um
keftazol keftalosan and azerbachter the
team collected 16 pairs of isolates
before and after exposure
the isolates were sequenced and the
genome analysis was conducted using the
rs cloud pipeline
once again a diverse set of resistance
mechanisms was it was identified
and again the mc beta lactamases were
among them
this time structural mutations more
clearly implicated the mc or omega loop
in the third study most recently
published in clinical infectious
diseases the team studies a case of
progressively evolving cephalocephalical
resistance um discovered in a a patient
suffering from lymphoblastic leukemia
sequencing identified an e coli strain
which was producing the metallobeta
lactamase the m5
[Music]
we can make this work here we go
five isolates were seek were
sequentially collected during the
treatment and subjected to rna-seq for
gene expression analysis to phenotypic
characterization and to whole genome
sequencing and ares cloud analysis
the expression analysis data shown here
further implicated by mdm5 and showed
that an increase in copy numbers and an
increase in elevated gene expression
levels correlated with increasing levels
of resistance to cephedracol
the phenotypic characterization
confirmed that differential gene
expression of blood ending 5 is in fact
associated with safiderical resistance
resistance to cepheidical can again be
reduced or if you will susceptibility to
cephelyrical increased when inhibiting
blah ndm5 through edta mediated binding
of its cofactor zinc as shown here in
the disk diffusion assays
finally genome sequencing and iris cloud
analysis of all isolates was conducted
the data showed that by ndm5 was
residing in a mobile element
and it also revealed mutations with
which implicated three other genes
listed here
i would like to focus on two genes in
particular env zet and r as both genes
are involved in modulating gene
expression
env has been associated in the
literature with an increase in
resistance to cepheidical it also
encodes for a cell signaling protein
controlling the dna binding
transcriptional regulator omr
remarkably mar mar
is as a dna binding repressor also
involved in transcriptional regulation
in fact it is also involved in in fact
it is involved in the global regulation
of or 80 genes in e coli
also interesting is the fact that mar r
has been associated with elevated
resistance to antibiotics through its
contribution to the acidification of the
cytoplasm potentially supporting
hydrolysis
of course further work is required to
elucidate the interplay between lie and
dm5 mutations in transcriptional
regulators in causing resistance to
suffiderocore these studies however show
that whole genome sequencing and ar
marker discovery is important to
identify biomarkers not only for the
presence but also for the up regulation
of amar inducing factors such as blind
em5
with that i will conclude the seminar
and thank our collaborators at johns
hopkins university and hospital
dr pranita tama dr patricia simla simner
and a doctor judith bergman
the authors will present more on their
research into detecting and treating amr
in an upcoming webinar and we will of
course share the dates and registration
details with you in the follow-up
so stay tuned
of course i would also like to thank you
for your attention and now use the time
and invite your questions
thank you dr materna for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
let's get started our first question is
we are a reference laboratory and
currently have to independently generate
genome data and
anti-biograms for each isolate can aries
technology be used to combine both steps
into a single workflow
thank you for that question uh can can
you in fact hear me does this work still
yes we can hear you excellent all right
perfect well the the answer to this
question is uh is yes in fact
quite a number of our partners
are
exploring the opportunity to gain deeper
insights into phenotypic resistance
directly from isolated genome data and
their main motivation is to save time
and cost
by avoiding
conventional ast especially in cases
that are time sensitive
examples here include
for instance rapid or positive blood
cultures
we have developed
predictive models for over 100
antibiotic compounds and are
continuously expanding the the ares
databases
with a focus on escape
uh pathogens and healthcare-associated
pathogens
uh if you have any specific questions
for instance with regards to supported
pathogen drug combinations uh
please don't hesitate to to let us know
either here or or by getting in touch
i hope that answered that question
wonderful thank you our next question is
amr profiling and predictive ast
especially in samples we collect for
infection prevention is very interesting
and would likely help us to improve
empirical selection of antibiotic
treatments
how can our microbiology lab access the
aries db
okay that's another good question and we
have in fact built a a user-friendly web
portal that i also referenced in in the
presentation called ares cloud
um
aerys cloud is is not only used by our
own
ngs service lab in vienna to deliver
results to our customers
but it enables labs with
their own ngs capacity to run queries
against the rsdb
aeroscout essentially automates the
entire bioinformatic analysis workflow
and returns
comprehensive information on amr
detected genetic markers their and their
prognostic performance
all of this is delivered on top of the
reports you'd conventionally expect for
isolated genome data including
information on sequencing quality
passage and identity msd and core genome
early typing results plasmids
and so on and ares cloud can be easily
accessed through our website www.aries
perfect thank you it looks like we have
one more question
we are excited to hear that aries
genetics is publishing validation
protocols for the isolate sequencing
workflow to support other labs in their
adoption of ngs we are planning to
establish ngs capabilities in our lab
next year do you offer some kind of
service that would help labs with the
setup of this or similar workflows
that's an interesting question we are
we're happy to share studies protocols
uh reference materials and of course
we're happy to elaborate on them
however to be compliant with regulations
uh i i need to point out that the actual
validation of laboratory developed tests
uh has to be
independently carried out by any lab
that is
essentially seeking to implement these
ldt's into their lab environment
but
lightening that burden for labs with
access to
ngs and aerys cloud and and enabling
them to generate pathogen data with
essentially the same accuracy as our
vienna based ngs lab that was in fact
one of the main motivations for us and
has remained one of the main motivations
for us to publish and share
the validation results protocols and so
on for the essays that we developed at
aries genetics
perfect thank you
i can see there's another question that
has come
in just now
yes i can
our next question is what is the
accuracy of predictive ast was it
correlated with the ast done at labs
yeah yeah this is a very good question
and sorry if that wasn't clear enough in
the presentation
uh this is in fact correct the accuracy
of predictive ast is measured in terms
of
um agreement with phenotypic traditional
ast
conducted under controlled uh
standardized conditions in clinical labs
so this is how we determine the accuracy
also the study i was referencing uh in
which we performed a multi-center
evaluation of predictive ast
is comparing the results of the
prediction with the
[Music]
phenotypic results conducted as i said
under controlled conditions in a lab so
it's very much a comparison of in
silicon generated results with lab
results and in this case we give the lab
results the benefit of the doubt and are
assuming that uh
they are the ground truth for the
purpose of this evaluation
perfect thank you
thank you again dr materna for your time
today and your important research before
we go i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr
materna
for his time today and his important
research we would also like to thank lab
ruth and our sponsor opjen for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay that's all for now
until next time goodbye